الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن قبل قليل للسكان
الفلسطينيين الموجودين في المناطق الغربيه
لمدينه غزه اصدر بيانا لهم بضروره مغادره
بعض الاحياء التي ذكرها في هذا البيان وهي
احياء النصر والشيخ رضوان ومخيم الشاطئ
والرمال الشمالي والجنوبي والصبره والشيخ
عجلين وتل الهواء وطلب من الفلسطينيين في
هذه الاحياء مغادرتها على الفور الى الام
الكن الامنه كما سماها في منطقه دير البلح
واذا ما نظرنا الى الخارطه نحن نتحدث عن
مساحه كبيره من المناطق الغربيه لمدينه
غزه يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي سوف يقوم
بعمليه عسكريه كبيره في تلك المنطقه وهذا
هو ربما ما يحمل التفسير لهذا الاجلاء
القصري لمن بقي من الفلسطينيين في هذه
الاحياء السكنيه ومن الواضح بان هذه
المناطق تحديدا المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه
ينه غزه تشهد في الساعات الاخيره اشتباكات
عنيفه ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه والجيش
الاسرائيلي كان بالامكان سماعها من هنا من
منطقه غلاف غزه كان يستخدم فيها الرشاشات
من العيار الثقيل وكذلك كان هنالك قصف
مدفعي متقطع باتجاه بعض المناطق يبدو انها
الجنوبيه حقيقه من الصعب تحديد مكان سقوط
القذائف المدفعيه والغارات الجويه التي
كانت ايضا هذا صباح بفعل الاحوال الجويه
العاصفه والمات والضباب الكثيف الذي يلف
المنطقه لكن يبدو ان الاحوال الجويه
العاصفه لا تؤثر على سير العمليات وعلى
القصف المدفعي والغارات الجويه التي كانت
في الساعه الاخيره ويبدو ان هناك اشتباكات
تتركز حاليا في المناطق الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الغربيه لمدينه غزه هذه المناطق
التي كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد استهدفها
يوم امس طيله النهار سواء بالغارات الجويه
العنيفه
والمتالق المدفعي المتقطع ولكن كان على
مدار نهار يوم الامس ويبدو ان الان
العمليه متواصله عمليه اطلاق القذائف
المدفعيه وكذلك الغارات الجويه التي تتركز
تحديدا في المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه في
ما بين المنطقه الجنوبيه والمناطق الوسطى
اي المخيمات الوسطى لقطاع غزه هنالك لواء
كامل يقوم بعمل تحصينات منذ اسابيع عده
ويفرض حواجز عسكريه على المحاور المؤديه
ما بين شمال قطاع غزه وجنوبها وهذا اللواء
عمليا يقوم بقطع اوصال قطاع غزه الى قسمين
القسم الشمالي والقسم الجنوبي ويحول دون
تمكن الفلسطينيين في المناطق الجنوبيه
الذين اي انتقلوا قصرا تحت القصف المدفعي
والجوي في الاسابيع عشور الماضيه من
العوده الى ما تبقى من ديارهم في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه واسرائيل تاخذ ذلك
كورقه مساومه كورقه ضغط على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في اي مفاوضات قد تنطلق وتتطور
الى صفقه تبادل تبادل الاسر لذلك واضح بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعزز من وجوده على
المحور المعروف برقم 10 وهو الشارع العرضي
الممتد من غلاف غزه حتى ساحل المتوسط يعزز
من وجوده العسكري يعزز من تحصيناته
العسكريه على هذا الشارع ويقيم الحواجز
العسكريه الكبيره كما فهمنا من بعض
التقارير العسكريه لمنع الفلسطينيين من
التوجه الى المناطق الشماليه والان بحسب
بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي قراناه قبل
قليل هنالك مطالبه ايضا للسكان
الفلسطينيين الذين بقوا في الاحياء
الغربيه لمدينه غزه بمغادرتها على الفور
الى المناطق الجنوبيه تحديدا الى منطقه
دير البلا عاد عن ذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول بانه ما زال يعمق من عمليته العسكريه
ويكثفها في منطقه خان يونس هنالك الان
خمسه الويه تعمل في اطار هذه العمليه
العسكريه بعد ان قام الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الايام الماضيه بسح بسحب لوائين اللواء
الرابع مدرعات واللواء 55 وهو لواء مظليين
من صفوف الاحتياط تم سحبهما من منطقه
خانيونس حيث اشتركا في الاسابيع الماضيه
في العمليات العسكريه هناك وهنالك تقديرات
على الاقل مما تشير اليه بعض وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه نقلا عن مصادر عسكريه
ومصادر في الجيش الاسرائيلي بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ربما سيعلن عن احكام سيطرته
الكامله على خان يونس في غضون ايام قليله
شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام من غلاف غزه